intention can matter when we're talking
about Prosecuting crimes but if the
action that is taken intentionally or
unintentionally is an egregious action
if it's against the law then there has
to be some punishment for it right for
the action itself not merely the
intention the road to hell is paved with
good intentions think about the
distinction between murder and
manslaughter yes it's true that we
prosecute murder more severely than we
prosecute manslaughter but we prosecute
manslaughter why because it's wrong to
kill a person whether you intend to kill
a person or not so is it wrong to
mishandle these classified documents or
is it not well he just he didn't he
didn't intend to ignorance of the law is
not an excuse ignorance of your own
actions is not an excuse either not
ultimately